the feris buer TV series seemed destined
to be a hit Not only was it based off a
classic movie the show also starred a
very famous friends actor so what went
wrong John Hughes to finded a generation
of Cinema for movie goers from The
Breakfast Club to Ferris bu's day off
the filmmaker created the archetype for
team movies in the ' 80s and early '90s
I've dealt a lot with the the problems
of being high school age this is about
the the undiluted Joy of being that age
as the writer director and co-producer
of Ferris bu's day off Hughes played a
major role in shaping the final film and
Hughes was so deeply invested in making
his vision come to reality that He and
Matthew brck would often get into
arguments about his acting style despite
the occasional butting of heads however
rodick and Hugh stayed in touch and even
discussed the possibility of a sequel
they even tossed around a few ideas for
a second film first when the ferris buer
TV series arrived neither brck nor
Hughes were involved instead John martiz
created the sitcom and served as a
showrunner for his only season on air
martiz is better known for being the
creator of Touch by an Angel and
Hawthorne feris bu's day off was made
for $5 million but went on to earn over
$70 million at the box office these are
the kind of numbers that make Executives
sit up and take notice at the prospect
of making more money off the franchise
however the people involved in making
the TV series underestimated the value
of those who made the movie so they
decided against bringing them on board
for Charlie schl the star of the sitcom
the series failed because the writers
didn't Jael with the material in an
interview with premium beat schl
explained it wasn't very good we had
good actors good directors and good
writers they just weren't the right
writers for this project we needed to be
doing what they were doing with Parker
Lewis Can't Lose when it ended I had
already emotionally moved on Parker
Lewis Can't Lose with another sitcom
that debuted in 1990 the series which
started kin neic as Parker Lewis holds
many similarities with Ferris buer both
shows followed a popular teenager and
his high school friends as they involved
themselves in all sorts of shenanigans
you're a very dangerous young man thank
you Miss muso get up unlike Ferris buer
though Parker Lewis Can't Lose run for
three seasons before she played Rachel
Green on Friends Jennifer Aniston
co-starred on the ferris buer TV series
in the sitcom anerson played Ferris his
antagonistic sister genie that's my
sister jeie overreacting thinks I get
away with
murder who's kidding who she has a car
and a no's job despite the sibling
rivalry on screen Aniston and schlat
were quite smitten with each other
offscreen writing for GQ Jim Nelson who
was a former assistant on the show
spilled the tea on the budding romance
between Aniston and schlotter Nelson
wrote everyone on set thought she was
hot including schlau with whom she had a
brief TD romance while playing it must
be said his older sister of course
there's nothing unusual about Romance is
developing between co-stars regardless
of which parts they play in the
production their relationship was
shortlived however and 4 years later
schl married Colleen Gunderson Ferris
bu's day off may have been released
nearly 40 years ago but it's still
universally loved by critics and fans
the film even holds an 82% critical
approval rating and 92% audience score
on Rotten Tomatoes the same come be said
about the TV show though which holds a
10% critical approval rating on the site
in its review of the show the Boston
Globe let loose stating brck Ferris was
a kind of high schooler that other kids
would want to hang with schls is the
kind other kids would want to hang
despite receiving mostly bad reviews
however Ferris buer did earn some praise
from the Los Angeles Times the newspaper
found the show to be entertaining enough
and Schat's portrayal of Ferris to be
slick and compelling for many fans the
name Bill Bixby is synonymous with the
1977 superhero series The Incredible
Hulk on the show Bixby portrays Dr David
Banner who turns into the terrifying
green monster While most viewers are
familiar with Bix B's Banner he also
appeared in other notable TV Productions
such as my favorite martian in addition
to being an actor Bigby directed
numerous TV episodes for a variety of
shows including Ferris buer the
filmmaker Helm the second and 11th
episodes of the series in Ferris bu's
day off the dean of students ated Rooney
serves as a main antagonist Rooney
suspects Ferris buer is up to no good
and wants to take him down not for the
TV series Richard reallyy takes over the
role of principal Rooney reallyy is a
notable and established character actor
having appeared in television shows like
grounded for life he also landed roles
in memorable films like office space I
have people's skills in an interview
with the AV club reallyy revealed that
he had never seen Ferris bu's day off
prior to auditioning for the series he
told the outlet up until then I hadn't
seen the movie but as soon as I got the
audition I saw it and I really liked it
really also said that watching the movie
helped him prepare for the role of Ed
Rooney you and me ber are having a
farewell party in my office I'm throwing
the book at you say goodbye to Ocean
Park High high school is featured
predominantly in the storyline of Ferris
buer seeing as the main focus as Ferris
and his teenage friends in 1990 team
shows such as Beverly Hills 90210 and
Parker Lewis Can't loose were all the
rage however teachers of the era felt
like many of these shows didn't
accurately reflect the actual High
School experience Mike moral a former
High School teacher told the Los Angeles
Times that a lot of these shows failed
to address what high school kids were
actually concerned with he explains how
many of his students were worried about
their future which was never covered in
the shows on television in the same Los
Angeles time piece John Martius explains
how the series was intended to be Breezy
entertainment from the get-go he told
the newspaper it's a comedy a teenage
fantasy with adult sensibilities and not
to be taken as anything more than that
he also defended the protagonist saying
the show is not mean-spirited Ferris
cares about his friends his family he is
a good person and he's honest he doesn't
take life that seriously no TV actor
thinks that show will be cancelled after
a single season especially if it's based
on an established property however FIS
buer was cancelled before his final
episode air after a strong debut in
August 1990 the ratings plummeted so the
network finally pulled the plug in
December however the show's final
episode did air until August 1991 in an
interview with no Today magazine Richard
realy said he didn't get a call to say
the show was done he also mentioned how
no one in the cast was even aware that
the show was in danger of being
cancelled saying we didn't even have a
rap party because everyone thought we'd
be back after we shut our last scenes
but things change however as early as
October 1990 the writing was on the wall
that the show's days were numbered
according to Richard reallyy Amy Dolan
wasn't the first choice to to play Sloan
Peterson in the ferris buer TV series he
couldn't record the other actor's name
he met at the reading but remembered she
looked exactly like Mia Sarah who
portrayed the character in the movie
version nonetheless really thought doens
did a great job of Sloan much like
really in the rest of her co-stars
Dolan's performance would always be
compared to a counterpart in the movie
however she didn't try to copy Mia
Sarah's performance Dolen told pop Geeks
I think I went a different direction of
course I saw the movie I loved it it was
a great movie but I did try and make it
my own a little bit more I'm not sure
what direction that was but I worked
with the actors and talked to the
directors and producers and just kind of
made it my own after starring in Ferris
buer dolin appeared in straight to video
films like tick she also guest starred
on TV shows like Rules of Engagement and
Murder She Wrote Dolan is the daughter
of the monkeys drummer and vocalist
Mickey Dolan out of all the actors to
appear in Ferris buer Jennifer Anderson
achieved the most success the show's
cancellation didn't prevent her from
becoming a television icon and the
leading player in Hollywood and while
the fairest buer experience didn't bring
her the career boost she may have
expected at the time Aniston did Channel
Genie bu's attitude in a later
performance in the 2016 comedy film off
his Christmas party Aniston portrayed
Carol vanstone the interim CEO who
threatens to lay off a large portion of
the company and cancel the Christmas
party as a result branch manager clay
played by TJ Miller concocts a plan to
save the employees jobs and host the
biggest Christmas Bash ever in an
interview with Vanity Fair Aniston
explained how Carol reminded her a lot
of Genie buer she told the magazine I
saw my character like a grown-up version
of Genie from Ferris buer my character
and TJ's character have this Ferris buer
or grown-up type of a relationship he's
always messing things up and getting
away with it while she never gets a
break she has a lot of resentment
because of that Jennifer Anderson and
her friends Co Styles made headlines
when they returned for a reunion special
in 2021 reunions aren't unusual in the
entertainment industry particularly for
sitcoms seeing as they have very loyal
audiences however don't expect to see
Anderson clambering for a ferris buer
reunion anytime soon when Access
Hollywood asked Anison about the
possibility of a ferris buer reunion the
actor said TV version of Ferris buer
would we see you guys ever come back and
do another reunion or it would be a
really absolute no hon went on to give a
more thorough explanation as to why she
wasn't interested in a reunion saying I
don't even think half of those actors
are even still in the business some of
them have left and gone to do other
really wonderful Noble things she went
on to reiterate that the possibility of
a reunion is a hard note from her in
terms of it ever happening Ferris buer
proved to be Charlie schluter's first
major DV role while the series failed to
become a Smash Hit It didn't derail the
actor's career schlat continued to find
regular work appearing in Diagnosis
Murder Touched by an Angel and the 1994
comedy police Academy mission to Moscow
however his biggest success came as a
voice actor schlat starred in popular
animated shows such as a fairly odd
parents and Kim Possible in addition
schlat provided the voice for the DC
Superhero the flash on numerous
occasions he showed up as a Scarlet
Speed Star in Superman the animated
series and has continued to voice the
character in other projects like Justice
League action so how many of schl
co-stars can say they starred in the
ferris buus TV series and went on to
become a member of the justice League
well not even Jennifer Aniston can claim
[Music]
that